hello YouTube averse Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist I just
got off of a video call with the
International Space Station a live
conversation with the two astronauts
there and knew whether we got Jessica
Mir and Christina cook
they'd spacewalk together recently and
got a little bit of that overview effect
so in this brief call we talked about
food politics Mars and also I have to
end with the comment about what it's
like to clean up vomit in case that
happens check it out are you ready for
the event Houston this is station we're
ready for the event station this is Neil
deGrasse Tyson with Startalk radio how
do you hear me hello Neil we have you
loud and clear how do you hear us
excellent excellent let's do this it's
great to have this time with you I think
they only gave us 20 minutes is that
must be when you're in this part of the
hemisphere so I'm gonna try to squeeze
in a whole lot of questions both of you
of course are scientifically trained and
I'm just wondering what kind of science
and engineering tasks or projects or
experiments have you been conducting
while you've been up there on the
International Space Station well we have
really been involved in every type of
science so far I have been up here for
about two months I have been involved in
an experiment growing mizuna lettuce
that's actually located right here next
to us you can see that due to different
light wavelengths here we've got a red
and a blue wavelength evaluating light
quality and fertilizer I've been
involved in a variety of physiological
and medical studies we have done
experiments looking at protein crystal
growth evaluating having potential for
future pharmaceuticals for various drugs
for various drugs for disease states we
have been involved in ultrasound studies
looking at different physiological
aspects like blood flow and how that
changes in microgravity really any type
of science you name it all combustion
experiments for example we have a
combustion rack
flames of course burn differently in
microgravity so a little bit of a
sampling of everything and I think
that's what keeps our job so interesting
is that it's not just you know pretty
for example my particular field of
expertise it's really all the aspects of
science combustion experiments that's
that doesn't sound safe I assume they're
fire extinguishers all around station
that is true there are fire
extinguishers all around station but we
do hope to never have to use them on our
combustion integrated rack of the
scientific payload rack where we do
combustion experiments they're in a
chamber that's you know obviously has
all the safety requirements needed the
interesting thing about that type of
experiment is how differently flames
burn in microgravity because you know
there's no convection to bring the hot
air up and create the shape of a flame
that we're used to for example on a
candle it's a very different environment
it allows us to get to some of the
fundamental properties of flames and it
turns out it's a lot more complicated
than you might think and the results of
those experiments not only affect and
benefit life on Earth in terms of fuel
efficiency and whatnot but it also
informs things like flammability for
products for use in space and space
travel one of my favorite experiments is
when you burn a candle in in zero-g and
then it just exhausts all the oxygen in
its environment and you ride with it
like you said without the convection a
candle will self extinguish I guess this
you see this when you do these
experiments yep that's absolutely true
and we see other really interesting
evidence of lack of convection here like
for example when we take our food
packets out of our little oven and set
them on the table to cool off it takes a
lot longer unless we actually put them
in an air pass so much we take for
granted here on earth just by living in
1g I have a quick question just I got to
settle this once and for all every bit
of physics I know tells me you are in
freefall towards Earth which renders all
of you weightless and everything in the
International Space Station so I would
call that zero-g where does NASA come
off calling it micro G yep that's a
great question I think the idea is just
the concept that everything that has
mass also has you know produces a
gravitational field so we might be wrong
to call it zero
just because I you know obviously
everything around me does have a nonzero
gravitational force associated with it
okay so then but they're very tiny
gravitational forces so we could just as
easily call it nan og couldn't we nano
Piko you know I'm not sure they actually
calculated that but it's definitely true
that we RL and freefall around the
planet and you know we are we are
experiencing the gravitational pull of
Earth which is actually what keeps us in
orbit around Earth so you could also
look at it that way that we're not
zero-g in that sense but the freefall
aspect of zero-gravity I'd say we're in
it did we land ourselves on the right
side of your argument I'm gonna look up
all my metric prefixes and see which one
actually applies to how much gravity
each one of you have on each other and
I'll get back to you on that yeah and I
think the other difference is that we
are constantly disturbing this
microgravity environment so anytime we
input a motion if we're exercising on
one on the treadmill or the cycle
ergometer on a red now we're disturbing
that pure that pure zero gravity force
that maybe an experiment desires just by
our human presence so we're still
disturbing that all the time so let's
talk about food the different segments
of the International Space Station
representing different countries who
participate and so do each of you like
trade food with each other when you get
bored with your meatloaf or something
I'm just curious how much food exchange
goes on on the International Space
Station well we do so nASA has a food
lab which you may know and they develop
most of our majority of the food that we
as American astronauts eat but the
Russians also have a food lab and we are
actually allowed to choose a certain
number of our food allocation from the
Russian food system so both Christina
and I like exotic and different foods
and so we went with a maximum majority
of Russian food that we could add we
also have some foods developed by the
year in space European Space Agency that
we can add to that mix we have a
European Space Agency astronaut up here
so we get to sample a little bit more of
that because he has a little bit more of
that than other people my goal was
actually to fly with the Japanese
astronaut because I love Japanese food
and I really wanted some of that but
unfortunately we don't have any of that
up here right now
but we do tend to share the Russians
will actually bring other things down to
us and we'll trade favorites back and
forth so I think variety is very
important for us up here even more
important than people would think people
that don't even care so much about food
on the ground do tend to in a
long-duration mission feel the need to
have some more variety and to make a
difference in terms of just that boredom
that develops otherwise I've eaten in
restaurants in both Italy and in France
and I'm guessing the French and the
Italians have no interest in trading
food with anybody else
well our Italian is pretty generous I
think one of the highlights on the food
system is the lettuce experiment that we
talked about earlier part of that
instead of sending all of the samples
down to be analyzed by the ground team
we actually get to harvest and eat the
lettuce so we've had two harvests now
where we get this fresh supplement
lettuce to our diet and that's a real
treat and we'll have another harvest the
day before we celebrate Thanksgiving so
we're looking forward to that so I've
been curious about that for long-term
space travel obviously there'll be some
expectation that you grow your own food
and is there how close are we to growing
all of your own food without requiring
sort of supply chains either to and from
the space station or to and from Mars if
that's our ultimate destination
absolutely great question I think that
right now we're at a place where we're
learning the best you know ways that we
can grow things in space but where we're
really looking to go is to develop
systems that are one closed-loop systems
so a system where we're using waste
products from various sources and
feeding those in to the actual plant
development and that can include our
carbon dioxide cycle our oxygen cycle in
our water cycle and we actually have
some really neat life-support systems
onboard right now that are testing some
of those technologies another aspect of
the food system that really has to grow
would be incorporating proteins right
now we have lettuce as our main you know
crop that we've grown we've grown
different things up here they've grown
flowers we're looking into starting into
vegetables and fruits but incorporating
protein sources like peanuts or maybe
legumes I think is the next sort of big
leap we're not quite there yet um as
Jessica mentioned we've had salad and we
joke sometimes that the caloric intake
that it's that we
you so far and growing it might be a
little bit more than what we end up
consuming but obviously the techniques
are what's important and proving out the
systems and the operational concept I'm
guessing that you're not gonna anytime
soon
start traveling with farm animals so
likely all of your protein will come
from plant-based sources which would
mean the future of space exploration
would be vegetarian that's what that
sounds like
maybe we're not sure you know we also do
have some other devices that are pretty
exciting up here right now we have one
facility called the bio fabrication
facility which is actually the goal of
that is to heart to grow human organs in
space now that's of course not for food
or consumption that is to contribute to
the deficit of organs for transplant
operations on the ground by any kinds of
efforts on the ground when you are
trying to produce these tissues and make
these bio artificial tissues there are
some problems with the support structure
for these and so the theory is that in
microgravity
we won't have that problem with the
support structures so we can better grow
these bio artificial tissues and then
turn them into complete organs going a
little bit along with that with 3d
printing we have other 3d printers up
here to make other pieces of hardware
the Russians also recently tested some
animal cells so some animal protein
cells to see whether or not they could
3d print meat so there are some
experiments that are looked trending in
that direction as well okay I don't know
I didn't think of that of course if you
can lab grow proteins meat proteins then
you never needed the animal in the first
place and then there's another source of
protein for you so an excellent
I'm just curious can you imagine a
totally self-sustaining place on Mars
and how soon do you think we can have a
self-sustaining Mars colony through are
we counting that in decades now not just
years because we know you can get water
on Mars and you know there's a fuel
maybe the rocket fuel if you just
elaborate a little bit about what's
there on Mars already versus what at
least initially we've got to bring there
to help you survive sure looking at the
current outlook and some of NASA's
long-term goals talking about going back
to the moon and the 2020s and then back
to the Mars and in
maybe the late 2030s so that would be
sort of an initial visit some of the
baseline mission design concepts would
be for you know a 15 month mission a
three year mission somewhere in that
range to do a sustainable mission I
think we are definitely talking decades
but I think it's important to have the
long term goal always in mind I've never
been someone that has been a fan of like
Tara transforming a planet to make it
you know more earth-like I think that
the excitement of going to a different
planet would be utilizing the institute
resources that are there so I would see
something like a sustainable Mars
establishment to me would always require
require some type of resupply and even
if that's just to make it livable and
habitable in terms of what humans think
of as habitable illimitable livable I
think is the important thing but using
the Institute resources as well yeah I
think the the you know when we if you
were to drive across the United States
there's basically a supply chain there
already for you you can stop at the Kwik
Mart and get food and something already
brought the food there for you to then
eat before you arrived
so maybe the idea of supply chain
shouldn't be viewed as something so
foreign because we actually thrive on
that here I'm curious about the the
future of robotics and artificial
intelligence there's a whole camp I'm
not in this camp that I'm about to
describe that would say do all space
exploration with robots do all space
exploration with robots and then you
don't even need the people you don't
have to bring the robot back so they're
cheaper and so um I know you guys are
astronauts but I'm just wondering what
kind of thinking you put into the idea
of robot astronauts for the future yeah
I've heard a lot of people debate that
as well you know maybe why do we even
care about human spaceflight maybe we
can do it all and with robotics and I
think the answer isn't one or the other
it's really a blend and the two can be
complimentary for different purposes and
for different reasons
we of course have had a lot of success
sending satellites and sending Rovers
and other spacecraft there are many you
know there have been several Rovers on
Mars that have provided a wealth of data
already and we haven't been there yet as
people so that's showing us that there
are some things that we've already been
able to do with these robotic spacecraft
that we haven't done yet with humans but
of course if you look at the other side
if you look at the statistics and what
these Rovers were able to accomplish in
terms of their exploration sending the
data back then being controlled by
people on the ground and having that
relayed back if they found something off
nominal or something that where they
wanted to go a different direction that
actually ends up taking months and what
the statistic that I've seen is that
what a rover can do in months or even
years astronauts can do on in minutes or
hours just because we have the
capability to problem solve directly
real time and then redirect as necessary
so I would see the future as involving
both I would love to go on a mission
with robots as well I mean we could
bring humans and robots together so just
to be clear your phrase boss nominal
really to the rest of us just means
weird
that's right sorry for the vernacular
there anything unexpected anything not
what wasn't programmed in for example by
the people on the ground as to what the
course would be if they saw something if
we saw something more interesting site
or more scientifically valuable in
another direction we could redirect
ourselves whereas the rover might be
programmed in one direction and would
miss out on an opportunity like that
promise me if any of you go to Mars and
you see something all phenomenal that
you won't you'll just say to NASA I see
something weird okay I want you to
promise me here and now I'm not sure we
can make those kind of promises to you a
question just about politics you guys
have been you guys have space walked as
so many visitors to the station do you
spacewalk together and you see earth and
that earth does not have color-coded
boundaries of countries and so surely
you get the news feed and who's in
conflict with whom and who's spying and
who's fighting this overview effect
which so much is written about how do
how do you see the future of politics in
space versus what's going on down here
on earth do you can space be something
that Lee
leaves all peace movements on earth how
much thinking have you guys done about
the role that space can play in the
future of this we both have been
fortunate enough to experience that
overview effect and I do think that it
you know has the option of improving the
world and the way that you talk about
one thing that we've learned is that you
know we get the question a lot too
politics on earth inform the way that
you do your job on here with an
international community and I like to
flip it around and say that the way we
do things up here actually can inform
our politics on earth so I think we do
see this as an example of how we can
work together for the greater good for
greater humanity and the fact that we
are more alike than we are different and
we all have the same goals it you know
at our roots and I think a specific
example of that both Christina and I
launched here to the International Space
Station having trained a majority of our
training in Russia in at the Gagarin
cosmonaut training southern center with
the Russian space agency we launched on
a Russian space vehicle to get here and
you know first many years now that has
been our only means of coming to space
and so that is something that especially
right now given the current political
climate may be surprising to some people
but for us all up here we're working
together as one crew and as one team and
I think that space has its ability to
actually transcend some of those
problems that we're having on the ground
so hopefully we here on the
International Space Station can provide
and maybe serve as an exemplary role
model for people on the ground as well
jokingly I've often said maybe a lot of
our world leaders need to come up here
and experience that overview effect for
themselves to truly understand what it
means that shouldn't be a joke that
should be real just a time for just a
couple more questions I just want to
have some fun questions so one of them
is I've sometimes been criticized for
commenting on the science of movies and
in the movie gravity Sandra Bullock's
bangs always pointed down and I'm
looking at your hair now doing its thing
doing it zero-g thing and so I I'm just
curious I don't know I guess that wasn't
a question I just want to tell everyone
look at your hair
in space in zero-g the hair does not
know which way down
is yeah there you go there you go yep
yep that's absolutely true I think our
special effects are a little bit better
up here maybe than in the movie gravity
but for me I was really surprised that
not only did my hair not float sideways
it actually just goes straight up which
makes sense in retrospect but you don't
really even expect that much but of
course there is no sideways in space if
there is no down or up so one final
question I being in zero-g presumably
would make you your stomach queasy at
some point certainly initially so I am
certain at least one of you have thrown
up in the space of the space station
before so how do you clean that up if
it's just scattering everywhere actually
both of us have been extremely fortunate
and neither of us have had the
opportunity to experience that not that
it could good and still happen for some
other reason but I think we'll probably
passed that risk period but we do of
course prepare for it because it does
strike many astronauts and you know you
don't really know who it's gonna be you
can't really prepare for it so we have
special motion sickness bags that we fly
with us in the spacecraft and that we
have up here in case anyone needs them
because like you said of course it's
going to be very difficult to contain
and I remember seeing that in person on
several flights that I did on the
parabolic flights on what we call the
vomit comet and observing some people
that tried to utilize the bags and
missed and that makes for quite a mess
especially with a plane because then you
experience experience the 2g but we are
equipped really to deal with that and to
deal with any kind of medical situations
up here with our training and all of our
supplies on the space station well
excellent guys thanks for taking the
time for Startalk radio and we got you
on video as well and so very much
appreciated this thank you very much
thank you nail it was our pleasure
station this is Houston ACR that
concludes our event as we count down to
20 continuous years of humans living and
working on the International Space
Station
[Music]